A Au Texas, Melissa Lucio,
mmère de 14 enfants condamnée
àà mort, a obtenu un sursis,
àà deux jours de son exécution,
ququi devait avoir lieu demain.
OnOn en parle avec Valérie
BeBeaudoin, chercheuse en
rérésidence à l'Observatoire
susur les États-Unis, à l'UQAM.
BoBonjour, Mme Beaudoin.
- - Bonjour.
- - Melissa Lucio est vraiment e
cacas type des inégalités face u
sysystème judiciaire aux États-
UnUnis.
- - Tout à fait, qu'Ypres provit
d'd'un milieu défavorisé, qui a
coconnu de la violence physique,
sesexuelle, émotionnelle, qui au
dedes démêlés avec la justice
popossiblement, bref, un cas de
pepersonnes qui n'avaient pas ls
momoyens de se défendre et qui a
étété reconnu coupable dans des
cicirconstances qui sont assez
nénébuleuses est inquiétante et
ququi, grâce à de la pression
auautant médiatique, politique,
dedevait être comme Kim
KaKardashian, assez de visibilié
popour se rendre à cette étape t
avavoir ce sursis.
- - Elle a été déclarée coupable
mamais elle a aussi été condamne
àà mort pour le meurtre de son
enenfant en 2007, sa fille, c'et
cece qu'on lui reprochait, c'est
dede ça qu'elle a été déclarée
cocoupable.
- - Tout à fait, à l'époque que
l'l'an 2000, elle était enceinte
dede jumeaux et sa fille de deux
anans qui avaient déboulé les
esescaliers quelques jours avant
soson décès, après, on l'accusen
raraison des contusions sur son
cocorps, on accuse la mère de
fafamille de l'avoir tué, on la
ququestionne pendant cinq heure,
elelle répond à 100 reprises son
ininnocence, qu'elle n'a rien ft
àà sa fille. Après toutes ces
heheures d'interrogatoire, il dt
: : je suppose que je n'étais. n
lele sait, vous avez découvert
bebeaucoup plus de procès que mi
leles angles quand quelqu'un n'a
papas nécessairement les moyensu
leles outils QUls peut dire
ququ'elle est innocente parce
ququ'il y a de l'acharnement, le
prpremier élément, elle a toujos
clclamé son innocence et il y a
vrvraiment des lacunes dans ce
dodossier parce que ses enfants,
onon a interdit qu'il témoigne u
prprocès, ils n'ont jamais accué
leleur mère de violence physiqu.
OnOn a assez caché le dossier
mémédical de la fille qui aurait
pupu expliquer la conclusion que
totous les éléments de la chute,
leles médias et les élus veulent
jujustement qu'elles soient
ininnocentées, mais il y a aussi
cicinq membres du jury qui dise:
cicible finalement, si on m'avat
prprésenté certains éléments, ma
dédécision aurait été une autre,
ilil y a de la culpabilité des
memembres du jury qui font tout
popour faire la même pression.
- - C'est étonnant, les jurés, e
ququi est aussi étonnant, c'est
cecet appui des partisans de ras
quque les républicains et les
dédémocrates s'unissent pour
dedemander qu'on sursoit à une
exexécution.
- - Au Texas que je peux les
cocompter sur les doigts de la
mamain, ce qui a de particulier,
c'c'est qu'il y a des républicas
ququi ont dit qu'ils espéraientl
y y a ce sursis de cette
exexécution, il y a même un qui
didit qui croit et sur abonnnne,
ilil souhaite que des gens
cocoupables soient exécutés, mas
dadans ce dossie clairement
ququelque chose qui a été négli,
esest-ce qu'on souhaite avoir
ququelqu'un qui me innocent qui
esest exécuté, une mère de
fafamille, il y avait toute
prpression politique et finalemt
ilil y a une cour d'appel qui a
trtranché en disant : oui, on va
sususpendre l'exécution, on va e
réréférer à une cour intérieure
popour vérifier plusieurs
éléléments. Entre, qu'on a caché
dede la preuve, est-ce qu'il y a
dede la preuve qu'il n'a pas et
prprésenté et qu'il aurait pu
l'l'innocenter? Est-ce qu'on a
prprésenté des preuves
frfrauduleuses? Est-ce que les
avavancées scientifiques
d'd'aujourd'hui pourrait prouver
soson innocence ou carrément es-
cece qu'elle était innocente à
l'l'époque de son procès et qu'n
a a pris une mauvaise décision?
ToTout ça va être à regarder avt
dede suggérer un nouveau procès,
ilil y a des étapes.
- - Qu'est-ce que c'est vrai que
lala prochaine étape? Un nouveau
prprocès?
- - Oui, on doit évoluer tout
d'd'abord les différents élémen,
ilil y a une recommandation quia
sese faire de cour intérieure àa
cocour d'appel qui aura le dernr
momot pour décider ou non il y
auaura ce nouveau procès. Avec s
nunuls éléments convient de
mementionner qui vont être
prprésenté, à mon avis, je crois
fofort bien qu'il y aura un
nonouveau procès pour cette feme
ququi est dans le couloir de la
momort depuis près de 15 ans.
- - On entende quand même assez
rararement des femmes qui sont
cocondamnées à mort, il y en a
pepeu.
- - J'ai regardé, les chiffres
sosont comptabilisés depuis 160,
avavant la formation des États-
UnUnis, avant l'indépendance ene
enentre trois et 4 % des exécuts
àà morts qui sont des femmes,
c'c'est très rare, ce sera la
prpremière femme latino-américae
àà être exécuté au Texas, et la
dedernière, c'était en 2014, c't
exextrêmement rare.
- - On vous suit cela et on vo